left on the seven day free trial of the
qurani app and it exceeded All my
expectations alhamdulillah I was worried
that was an overrated product that's
we tried it what was the system you can
build a habit with the Quran by seven
day free trial promises no credit card
details required at all download it and
see what time it is
all that happened was he misconstrued
his arguments he didn't get them correct
my argument was from the argument from
contingency okay
um
okay I don't really dealt with
philosophy
um not too much like I don't really I
even discourage some people too however
the contingent argument I use it in the
form even team you use this yes so I do
it to affirm God Almighty and then if I
then use it to affirm his attributes
yeah so my argument is an argument from
contingency do you know what do you want
to take it out okay so it's very simple
yeah we have three kinds of
possibilities we have possible existence
we have a necessary existence and we
have impossible existence okay The
Impossible existence is that you have a
triangle square or a triangle Circle do
we accept that that's an impossibility
yes okay so we are left with two
possibles okay which is
um
contingent uh possibility and necessary
necessary existence yeah okay so those
two other uh the area that I'm going to
focus on yeah okay now do you accept
that there are contingent things within
our universe okay no before we start
this okay where do you think contingency
comes from the idea where'd you think
because they didn't come out of nowhere
where do you think the idea of
contingency okay so when you say the
ideal contingency obviously I think
people use their logic a rationality
okay to come to certain conclusions for
example that we have things within our
universe that is dependent okay so
therefore if there are things that are
dependent we cannot have an infinite
regress of dependent thing which is my
second argument that if there are
dependencies do we accept that there is
dependence I don't because where does
the dependency come from okay it's the
same place where continuity comes I'm
John I'm just trying to dig into it
that's fine where it comes from so you
do not believe that there are dependent
things in our universe what is
dependency okay where does the need for
dependency come from something that
relies on something else for his own
existence yes so it sounds really like
14th century arguments proposed by Marc
Spinoza which were over 600 years ago
that's fine yeah
yeah but that's got nothing to do with
so you're dependent I'm dependent in the
physical sense not in the moral sense
but what you're proposing is the moral
sense no no I'm not yes because
contingency is inherently a moral
argument no no I'm using argument but
didn't you see to prove that there's a
higher power which is a necessary being
that gave rise to us so I'm not using it
from the most sense what I'm saying is
do you accept that you are dependent on
other factors to your survival yeah
essentially saying that there is a chain
of dependency to you rely on other
attributes and that makes you dependent
being you depend on other things for
your continued existence and this chain
of dependency will last forever unless
there is a necessary being at some
points it has to change
but this is my issue with the argument
so a necessary being how do we Define
this as a thing that does not depend on
any other attributes
okay I'm saying that there does not rely
on any other things to depend on for its
continued existence a necessary being is
not dependent it's not contingent on
anything else yes it's necessary it's
still sufficient yes and it cannot be
any other way okay
so and this is my finger but surely God
is composed of pieces no he has certain
actions yes all loving all caring if you
would like to believe in such a deity
then you need to accept that God does
depend on certain attributes and can be
became other than himself this is where
I'm talking about the contingent
argument that you're using and what I'm
using I'm making it very clear before we
even counter that yeah I believe his
attributes are an essence essence it's
himself I don't divide it and go the
most merciful oh we have another
necessary being I don't say that at all
you said that so just to make something
clear before we come to that do you
accept there are like we said there are
dependent things within our universe yes
okay now do you accept that we cannot
have infinite regress of dependent
things
where does the idea of dependency come
from okay one second if I said God
exists and that is a fact and it is you
will laugh at me you say to me
no there is evidence what I'm saying is
what you're proposing to me is the
universe just is it's a brief fact
closer chapter no no no that's not what
I said
we say that okay raise it you want to go
for the simplest explanation with the
least assumptions and God has an
assumption to explain this Universal
assumption where does God come from okay
this is what I'm saying okay this is my
argument so let me repeat again there
are dependent things within our universe
there cannot be an infinite regress of
dependent things therefore we require a
necessary being who is self-sufficient
who is not composed to places and cannot
be any other way take his wife
independent things within our universe
now do you accept is the universe
dependent or independent independent
independent now what you've done which
is good which is
you accept a independent being but
you've described it okay you accept
Independence you've ascribed it to the
universe so we are on the same page and
what we say is this that's good now
you've accepted the necessary thing all
you've done is you said it's not God
it's the universe now is the universe
unless the question is the universe
composed of pieces yes then it cannot be
necessary it is dependent yeah okay but
this is the weights wait wait these
these are all the these are all
assumptions these are all
depends on different attributes the
universe
actually has a fallacy of conversation
because she said look the United
composed to Pieces all of these pieces
have causes therefore the universe
to making assertion about the whole but
even if foreign
but what if the wall is red so I'm not
even using the argument from composition
because that's the argument from
um
about composition I'm saying again I
repeat you said the universe is
necessary I said well that's good
because now we agree that we require it
necessary
you've ascribe it to the universe I said
one second I said is the universe
composed of pieces you said yes if it's
composed of pieces it cannot be
necessary if it's not necessary it is
dependent if it is dependent the problem
is the problem at first if it is
dependent what is it dependent on did
you understand yes I get that completely
but the problem is is that all of these
assertions are inherently grounded
within an understanding of the world
that is inherently Islamic and it's
inherently religious it's religious no
no no but yes yes but where your
arguments come from historically
actually I'm telling you I'm telling you
I'm telling you exactly where they come
from
how old
in the Islamic Golden Age the Islamic
Golden Age 800 years ago 900 years ago
whatever time has come yes yes listen
this and this time has come this
Humanity has gone through it's a phase
of development for outside these
arguments that you're telling me now are
arguments that
um you know like logic like people that
were Professionals in logic yeah but
just and they proposed them because they
did not they didn't have scientific
understandings to explain the world so
they needed to explain the world which
suited the Christian the religious the
Islamic the juju Jude by yeah this is
their interpretation of the world and
that logic was important employed with
that purpose because there was no other
there was no science was shown science
was some and logic was the only answer
this is exactly what you're telling me
let's say I go with that yeah how is
that the Supreme argument because
because it exists in a framework that
has now we now have a better explanation
for example the universe is composed of
space and it's hard and if I if I cause
this brothel to drop yes there's space
in which it drops and the time from when
I put my hand on and it falls this is
the universe outside the universe this
idea of cause and effect and that
something having to come into we don't
even know how the universe functions
collapses outside this this is the logic
which is ultimately bound up in the
universe so this is a great mystery yes
because I think it the the mystery and I
accept that rational up my rational
faculties cannot comprehend the reality
outside the one we immediately observing
and I and I think and I think to say the
universe it depends on something yes it
depends on it it's the end yes it does
it does it doesn't necessarily how does
that disprove my argument
give me a history lesson yeah you've
told me about the uh that's
understandable how does that
so this is a very important point I need
to ask you okay so you're saying that
the universe is uh dependent it's a
contingent um entity yes because it
depends on lots of things within it you
accept that he said the universe is
independent do you accept that I'm
independence of war no no no it's just
independent it's independent no it's
just independent it's self-sufficient
it's not does not rely on anything first
continued existence yes I I do yeah okay
good so you do and you do do you oh yes
you guys it's independent great
gentlemen here are all in sync you all
believe that the question I'm asking is
the following please listen carefully if
the universe is independent means it is
necessary firstly that means we both
accept that we require a necessary being
where does necessity come from now
what's it one second the fact that
there's dependent things you require
something that's necessary to give rise
to it now I'm asking a question is the
universe composed of pieces or can the
universe be any other way
if there were four less galaxies is that
still the same universe no okay so there
are probably galaxies blowing up and
destroying so that means the universe
can be other way and the universal
composed of pieces that means it cannot
be necessary it is dependent now listen
carefully if it is dependent what does
it depend on I'm saying it's not to jump
you've made an assumption you make these
jumps and there's some things you look
at the pieces and you're saying look
they have cause and effects
but it's dependence or something else
let me give you an example yeah okay A
mother can give birth to the child it
caused the child but the child doesn't
necessarily depend on the mother for his
survival yeah so know the difference I'm
not using the Kalam cosmological
argument I'm using the argument from
contingency yes yes so I'm repeating
again you guys said I said what did you
see in the beginning necessary and
contingent we've got rid of the
impossible existence so now what do you
guys said is the universe is independent
and necessary I said okay let's go with
that however you're saying that I'm
jumping the gun how am I I'm saying you
guys said the message the universe is
independent I don't I never said
necessary I've listened necessity
necessity is two different things if
it's independent yeah then I said to you
one of my arguments was
one any other way and if it's composed
of pieces it cannot be independent it is
dependent if it's dependent what is what
do the pieces have to do
what is it Dependable it's a simple
question this is my answer that
inherently it being composed of pieces
you know how do you visualize pieces how
do you Village no no I'm asking you a
question how do you visualize this yes
exactly but what are pieces in the
universe for example that we are a piece
of the universe yes yeah we are okay so
what I'm saying is if I cease to exist
yeah okay that means the universe can be
any other way I don't need you I could
be another way so therefore it shows
it's dependency no because what it does
show is that we have a certain logic in
humanity we have so we have a certain
Logic on Earth and certain things work
differently than they do in the universe
it's two different Frameworks yes yes
yes guys it's very simple you've
accepted an independent thing and he's
called it the universe I'm saying okay
I'm with you guys I'm on your team but
I'm saying the universe can be any other
way we said yes and we said Can is it
composer pieces we said yes that is not
my definition of a independent being
right so what I'm saying is how can it
be independent and necessary when you
have given the attributes of a dependent
thing no what I'm saying what I'm saying
it needs to be necessary to prevent this
cause it's necessary look if it's
necessary then why is it composed of
pieces why is it the very idea of
necessity is a moral one they've got
moral morality morality brings about
necessity yes yes but what is necessity
and that's a great question I started
our debate with what something that okay
it's necessary self-sufficient yeah
cannot be any other way and it's not
composed of pieces okay that's my
definition of a message
thank you but that's what I'm saying
thank you I'm seeing it cannot be
self-sufficient because of the following
it is composed of pieces number one
because it shows that it's dependent it
could be anything
is there galaxies within our universe
yes yes if we have five less galaxies
yeah what happens I'm not the same it's
a different Universe no not really
though because galaxies blow up and
explore still still okay okay okay I
have your argument I understand
but how does that accommodate the fact
that the universe is expanding what's
the second Dynamics
of the universe is it goes towards
okay but it's an open system okay no no
what I'm saying is this yet is there a
set amount of energy within our universe
no it's expanding this is my point but
at one point if you reversal that's why
the Big Bang Theory comes from if you
reverse it they go to a similar point if
there is a set amount of energy within
our universe it is dependent on
something else if you hit if but there
isn't it's now being proved is it
infinite infinite because universe is
expanding
attention
the universe is expanding
another expansion
if I say I have infinite amount of
biryanis and I eat to be Rihanna's how
many biryanis do I have still infinite
no it's infinite minus two which is an
impossibility there is no such thing the
concept of infinity doesn't exist in the
real world yes there is potential
infinite but it gets infinite so now if
you're saying infinite it's my point it
doesn't exist in our world okay our
world is the only word I'm talking about
yeah in our universe if there is no
infinite then that shows that it is
finite if it's finite it requires
something else obvious outside itself
for its existence which shows its
dependency yes yes I understand exactly
I understand exactly but that logic that
logic is very good
no no no that logic is very good
not saying The Logical scaffolding
you're using to craft your argument yes
it exists
you're right but within the universe
within time and space and this idea of
dependency in court
but outside this logical framework these
Concepts simply do they just simply
collapse all I'm saying no no listening
can I say you might be so the way I
perceived before that you didn't accept
that no no but what I want to say is my
honestly what I want to say is my view
that where these where do the ideas of
necessity all of this contingency where
they come from they come from they come
from a need to unify a people whether
this is where does Islam come from where
did where did the Christianity come from
where did Judaism come from it came from
the idea of repressed tribes repressed
people within a within a former within a
bigger Empire that needed something to
stand behind neither something yes yes
no I'm just telling you my view and from
which these your other views come from
because then you then you come to the
point where okay let's say you're you
know 1500 years ago when Muhammad you
know when Muhammad came about and he he
like he he like you know United the the
Arab people to be nice of these tribes
and created this huge Islamic empire
destroyed two empires while doing it yes
and created this forces they were trying
to destroy them yeah yeah but he
destroyed them but then yes yes but as a
coherent entity yeah yeah he came in and
destroyed them yeah so that's the point
but how else do you unify a people how
do you unify people I understand by you
yes but then but then that's the
question okay use Islam Islam is there
no no no no yes I'm not I'm not this is
I'm just telling you my my perspective
on where your views come from yeah so
that and and then you come to the
situation where you don't have the
science to describe to explain the
universe you don't have you don't have a
way you don't have a physical
technological way of understanding what
the universe is what do you employ you
employ logic that is inherently grounded
to our perception of the world within
planet Earth without understanding
what's going out out there that's fine
you use uniformity irregularity and
certain things to do science necessity
my friend your friend my friend
necessity no no that's you've got you've
given me a kind of a history lesson
slash moral I'm not even talking about
that yet I know this pen with this do
you wake up and this pin explodes
yes okay so we know we can do science if
that didn't happen we could never do
science that's why we look at quantum
mechanics and we talk about the double
experiment yeah there are things that
happen in which we're like oh that you
know that doesn't make sense to us so we
use our rationality irregularity
uniformity to do science I'm giving you
guys an argument yeah that's inherently
moral no no look I'm not using a model
of argument yes but I'm very moral but
I'm saying that very simply I've made an
argument you guys haven't given me
anything
um to the spirit I just want to come and
say you know Ali the universe isn't
necessary and independent because of a b
and c I do know where we did no what are
your what's here what's the issue of it
you're saying that the Universe kind of
needs something a necessary being that
gave rise to it then I could come and
talk to you about his attributes and
you'll enjoy defining a necessary being
yes as something that doesn't isn't
composed of power but he says again
again I you cannot be any other way yes
and it's Independence independent
self-sufficient yes
and I'm saying I'm seeing that under
these your terms and your definition and
this the definitional structure that
we're using to construct the arguments
on yeah under the definitions that we
have agreed you you
um are accurate in your fashion that the
universe is composed of Parts but I what
Alexis is ultimately saying is that this
argument is archaic and does not reflect
the reality that the Universe could have
been
um could have been is not necessary not
necessarily because no because no this
is my point
Sorry the the unit the universe isn't
um contingent doesn't necessarily have
to be contingent on something else
definition yes that's true so you accept
it I'm saying under the definition that
we have agreed upon no no no
because yes the universe is composed of
certain attributes this is this is true
so it immediately prevents it from being
a necessary being if we're going to
disagree them we have to disagree on the
definition thank you but I'm saying that
this definition is ultimately irrelevant
because the universe could re could
conceivably have been caused from
nothing any good but not cool I'm not
talking about causation yes from nothing
where does the idea of Mississippi
I'm not composed of nothing I'm saying
that I assume no you said it can be I'm
sick Under The Logical framework that's
illogical
under our logical framework that is that
we use to comprehend our perceptions of
the natural world yes then it seems
inconceivable something can come out of
nothing exactly but this this is still
it's not an impossibility it's enlisted
at this the three different things but
this is nothing a possibility it is
because outside of our logical framework
outside of the universe it could be
conceived
the process by which chemical reactions
take place could be totally different
this is I think this is more likely than
positing a deity and this is where we
all disagree on the master of
probability
I use the argument from contingency so
now you guys have not touched up in
number one now you are asserting that
look at this can it be God no way can it
be nothing maybe that is preposterous
let me tell you let me finish I listen
to you let me finish it what is nothing
the absence of something if I go to my
message and say zero can equal one he'll
give me a back hand and make me fly back
to the class under the classroom of
course you are now asserting the most
Preposterous position which is it can
come from nothing can it be good no way
can it be nothing
you ascribe the necessary being to the
universe we showed you guys that the
universe is composed of my pieces can
can be an any other way so we realize
that it's dependent then we said what is
it dependent on a necessary being but
it's independent it is not composed that
pieces and it cannot be any other way
now that is my argument and you guys
haven't said anything yeah now do you
accept that now a necessary being is
required for the universe two let me ask
you a question first
because you've not answered my first
question no no let me ask you a question
that I began this debate with what's
this okay your your definition of
necessity your definition of necessity
is very carefully crafted according to
your own service ignore it according to
your own interpretation well if you look
at what is necessity why do humans need
something like necessary where does it
really come from no it's not really yes
I have
you got about 50. let me finish it's
been about 15 to 20 minutes yeah I have
not heard no because you're not
answering my questions I have not heard
one counter argument towards you gave it
you gave me an example about the Islamic
history you said to me about nothing
seems to be to you guys I I I I'll
answer the question again here's my
please tell me okay
you guys said the universe is
independent yeah good then I said the
universe cannot be independent because
it is composed of pieces and it cannot
be any other way this is my problem let
me finish guys let me finish then we
acknowledge that the universe is
actually dependent not independent
Library
one second then I said then what is the
universe dependent on and you guys
haven't been honest no because I'm this
is my point
no because listen the point is
dependency dependency is a moral
argument like I said at the beginning
what was my definition in the beginning
yes your definition I don't agree with
that definition yes but that's your
definition that's your definition
no no I'm telling you I'm asking you a
question definition this is no no this
is the
points
my point is necessity the idea of
necessity I disagree on that because
that is absolute because necessity is
inherently a moral trait yes yes
irrelevant no it's not irrelevant
because
necessity it comes out of Humanity's not
yes yes no no listen listen let me talk
necessity comes out of Humanity's need
to understand to understand itself it
doesn't this idea that you connect to
parts and pieces of parts to necessity
that has nothing to do with it the
universe can be the only way it can be
the universe is not connected to human
logic it's not connected to necessity
it's not connected these two different
science not use regularity and
uniformity to do this study of course it
does
uniformity and regularity has got
nothing to do with pieces in the
universe in order for you to do studies
you need to know that when I use a pen
for an experiment it doesn't bloody
explode yes there's uniformity yes
otherwise you can never do science but
not you never know that one second we
use our logic and certain laws are in
place to make true science I'm giving
you guys a logical argument and you're
here telling me no we reject your
definition or what basis oh which is D
no I didn't say that no I said it on a
very good basis on a moral basis I
rejects that's my question yeah what
does the Universe depending nothing
because the universe you don't need a
dependency when I'm ready to speak okay
you said the universe doesn't depend on
anything yeah and you are the same
person who said the universe is
independent yeah but what is your
definition of independence what's your
name Alexa what is your definition of
independence listen to me yeah and let's
see if he was Alexis I would say Alexis
listen yeah listen to me you're seeing
the universe is independent now that I
prove this interdependent Okay
Okay let's listen to none no listen to
reply you said the universe is
independent I prove that is dependent
now what I say was depending on you've
got nothing but you didn't prove it you
proved it was dependent according to
your understanding of what dependency is
which I'm telling you is inherently
immoral and it comes out of your
religious beliefs what is the universal
close to pieces thank you
that does not define it yes it is okay
can it be any other way
how is that dependent though what's that
dependent on
dependent
okay no no exactly this is good this is
good you've talked now we can talk
properly the the idea is dependent on is
inherently moral and it's based in
Humanity's wanting to understand
something that it can't perceive how do
we perceive the universe you talk about
galaxies
yes but what is necessity
so can we just make this point by the
same standard so you're seeing the
universe you even said it can come from
nothing
else
necessary deity you're saying that can
come through now yes but what is
necessity my friends I've given my
definitions about the definitions for a
contingent thing definition for lesser
beam okay you have not answered this is
this is the point we want to afford it
okay
because this is my point where this is
I'll answer the simple question my
argument was very simple yeah okay there
are dependent things within our universe
there is and there is Independence okay
so I said dependence is something that
can be any other way it's composure
pieces and requires something else for
its own existence yes then my dear
friend said that I said is the universe
dependent on Independent he says
independent then I said to him it cannot
be independent because it's compulsively
and it can be any other way so we
acknowledge that it's dependent
okay okay so and then I said to them
since we agreed this dependent what does
it depend on he said maybe from nothing
he said it depends on nothing so my
argument is very simple the atheists are
terrified to say sorry it can be good it
can be nothing it can't be related
anything in the internet
that's my closing statement you guys
okay okay
thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
is that necessity is an inherently it's
a moral construction because where does
the idea of necessity come from where
does it look where do you really like
when when you wake up every day when you
when you think about God why do you
think about God why do you because you
believe it's necessary to your own
existence that what Ali's done is now
and is now zoomed out and it pulls out
on the whole universe and then put his
own definition of what dependency is
which I don't agree with I don't think
dependency consistent was I think
dependency is one of one of the things
which you listed which is the third
thing which is it has to depend upon
something which is what he said that is
the one thing I I agree but this is why
I said it's not dependent it's
independent it's got nothing to do with
our understanding of logic with our
understanding of morality of our
understanding of necessity because we're
using our values we are using our
understanding of how to live our lives
and imposing that upon a system that's
inherently can only be understood
through science through physics through
these in through these subjects which
have nothing to do with necessity the
big band The Big Bang has nothing to do
okay
I believe that the the argument that the
universe is
Dependable comes from the fact that you
look at the pieces and you say well this
is independent this is dependent on
something else therefore the entire
universe must be depends on something
else which is the fallacy of composition
translation argument which I reject
which I didn't use I must have
misunderstood your arguments
dependence forgive me
that was it yes that's it guys thank you
for coming back but my dear friends here
I would like to carry on the description
I'll be back next week